i donated my kidney to my boyfriend and
he cheated on him this is that story
this all started in the beginning of
2015. so we met through mutual friends
he was really cute and outgoing and
um
oh sorry
we would take turns making drives um to
see each other and hang out and then
early on he told me he had chronic
kidney disease and crohn's disease so he
had to connect to a machine every night
to filter out his kidneys at that time
he was 27 and had it for 10 years just
knowing that his kidney function was
already below 5 it made me have this
urgency to help him i didn't want to
wait to you know have his
condition get worse or he could have
passed away too
in order to donate you have to be in
good health they have to do tests to
make sure your body can survive with
just one kidney and so i had to do a
bunch of tests to see if i was a match
probably around three four months going
to his doctor and getting blood work
done and a glucose test
different types of scans and then in
november that's when i got the call the
doctors told me my body was ready to go
and i was ready for surgery so i was the
one who chose the day to be may 23rd
because 23 is my favorite number i was
born on december 23rd and
michael jordan is my favorite player so
i was tempted to youtube the procedure
before just to see just to get an idea
what my body's gonna go through but
i didn't and i i'm glad i did
surgery was pretty easy they put me
under anesthesia so i was knocked out
the whole time once i woke up i just
remember waking up to tubes in my mouth
and they tried feeding me you know ice
cubes and i almost threw up
but other than that i just went back to
sleep and
it took me about
two weeks to recover like to feel back
to normal so my doctor only recommended
me to not drink you know a lot i don't
drink a lot anyway so it wasn't really a
big sacrifice to me and to not do
physical sports like boxing and i was
totally okay with that
so for him his lifestyle change they
took the tube out of his stomach so he
didn't have to go do dialysis anymore he
just had to take anti-injection pills
and
pain medicine his family was really
grateful and they cried a lot it just
felt great for the both of us a few
months after the surgery my boyfriend
went to a bachelor party in vegas with
some of his christian friends um his
best friend was getting married he was
texting me throughout the trip how much
he didn't want to be there and how much
he just wanted to read the bible and
then i responded to him like no just
enjoy yourself you know you don't really
go to vegas too often and
you know you're with your friends you
don't have to go under dialysis anymore
so
you know just have fun i didn't think
anything was going to happen in vegas
because he
portrayed himself as a really religious
man and he stuck through his morals
throughout the relationship and so i
thought this was just a regular weekend
on the sunday that he was coming home he
came to my house unannounced panic in
his eyes and just like pale like he
looked really scared and i was just
confused on what happened and then
that's when he admitted to the cheating
he
admitted to doing things with some of
the bachelorette party it's funny
because
those girls knew who i am and i know one
of them was a close friend to mine too
and i was
just
broken and then after he came and
confessed what he did
i had to go to work i had to go to work
at disneyland the happiest place on
earth i was scheduled to work at the
churro cart at pixar pier and i really
didn't want to cry in front of the
guests one of my co-workers knew
something was wrong and then he asked
are you okay and that triggered me just
the tears just
fell down my face and i just couldn't
stop crying and then
my lead let me go home for the night i
thought about it for a while and i
decided to try to make things work maybe
he deserved another chance maybe
we can work it out and make it
make it happen for us and
after everything that happened it
definitely hurt my trust issues with him
and it was hard to trust again
especially when i thought he wouldn't do
anything behind my back
it did lead to a lot of fighting and
insecurities we fought a lot about me
not giving him enough trust and it just
felt repetitive it really took a toll on
our relationship one day we were
fighting about
him
resenting me of not being forgiving fast
enough and in the middle of the argument
he wanted to stop and read the bible
together i was like no can we kind of
just talk like regular
people and that's when he just
shut down and pretty much said like oh
if god wanted us to be together then
he'll bring us back together in the end
and hung up
after he hung up on me he blocked me on
social media and
yeah just completely cut me out i felt
really hurt that he could just you know
throw me out of his life like that i
would work at disneyland five days a
week and it was kind of hard to you know
keep that smile throughout my shift but
i decided to make peace with the
situation
and decided to stop trying to contact
him even after everything has happened i
still don't regret
donating my kidney to him despite the
trauma and the heartbreak that i had to
go through it did lead me to
a better life and that's how i met my
current boyfriend and with someone who
really loves me unconditionally i
haven't been happier i'm not mad at him
i don't hold any grudges against him i
only wish him well and for him to live a
happy life i don't want my kidney back
go ahead and have it and make sure you
treat it well
[Music]